chaulk ministre des finances et chef du
parti social-démocrate située à gauche
qui a gagné les élections on est loin de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne
défendue par notre président pour une
europe qui protège l'allemagne a pris
conscience et assument de plus en plus
ouvertement quelle est la puissance
centrale en europe le programme commun
qu'il s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre ne va
pas dans le sens des intérêts français
[Musique]
et
à quelques heures de la nouvelle année
la traditionnelle allocution du
président la dernière du mandat d'
emmanuel macron à quatre mois de
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 la
crise sanitaire la présidence française
de l'union européenne qui débute demain
la reprise économique seront sans doute
au coeur des thématiques développées par
le chef de l'état
[Musique]
il
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france pour
une nouvelle page d'actualités
comme chaque année à 20 heures le
président va s'adresser aux français
dans quelques secondes le chef de l'état
qui a préparé son discours au fort de
brégançon lieu de villégiature de
villégiature pardon des présidents de la
république avant de rentrer à paris pour
s'adresser au pays il arrive on
l'écoutait immédiatement
on
[Musique]
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes de métropole d'outre-mer et
de l'étranger à nouveau cette dernière
soirée de l'année est marqué par
l'épidémie et les contraintes renforcée
qui pèsent sur notre quotidien alors en
ce moment j'ai avant tout une pensée
pour nos 123 mille compatriotes à qui le
virus a enlevé la vie une pensée pour
tous ceux qui traversent ce moment dans
le deuil la peine ou la solitude
je n'oublie pas non plus ceux d'entre
vous qui sont touchés par le cos vie de
longs comme ceux qui subissent les
conséquences psychologiques de la crise
sanitaire
je veux ce soir une fois encore en votre
nom à tous témoigner notre
reconnaissance pour nos personnels
soignants pour nos armées nos forces de
l'ordre nos sapeurs pompiers nos
auxiliaires de vie nous aide à domicile
et tant d'autres professions tous
engagés ce 31 décembre
comme chaque jour pour nous protéger
pour prendre soin de nous
les semaines à venir seront difficiles
nous le savons tous le virus circule et
circulera de plus en plus des mesures
ont été prises par le gouvernement pour
y faire face et je vous demande à tous
et tout d'y veiller des secteurs comme
la culture le sport la restauration
l'hôtellerie le tourisme ou
l'événementiel vont à nouveau subir les
conséquences économiques de cette
situation nous les aiderons comme il se
doit et comme nous le faisons depuis le
début de cette pandémie il y aura aussi
nombre de nos activités désorganisés en
raison de ce nouveau variant si
contagieux nous veillerons dans ce
contexte à assurer la continuité des
services publics et de la vie de la
nation mais par rapport au même moment
l'année dernière où les contraintes
étaient beaucoup plus forte nous avons
pour nous l'arme du vaccin et les acquis
de notre expérience collective et donc
de vraies raisons d'espérer
nous sommes ce soir au moment où je vous
parle plus de 53 millions à être
totalement vacciner ce qui place notre
pays dans le peloton de tête mondial
nous sommes 24 millions à avoir reçu une
dose de rappel et notre objectif est de
permettre à chacun d'être vacciné et de
faire son rappel nous pourrons ainsi
surmonter cette vague en limitant au
maximum les restrictions en continuant
comme nous l'avons fait depuis le début
de tout faire pour préserver l'activité
est ce que nous avons de plus précieux
c'est à dire l'école l'éducation de nos
enfants
alors ce soir je veux le redire avec
beaucoup de force et beaucoup de
conviction la vaccination est notre plus
sûrs atouts elle réduit fortement la
transmission elle divise par dix le
nombre des formes graves c'est pour cela
qu'une nouvelle fois j'en appelle aux 5
millions de non vaccinés fait ce geste
simple pour vous pour vos compatriotes
pour notre pays toute la france compte
sur vous
la vaccination est elle seule suffisante
non c'est pour cela que le respect des
gestes barrières contre le virus demeure
essentiel en particulier le port du
masque tous ensemble nous allons donc
traverser cette nouvelle épreuve en
suivant les mêmes principes que depuis
le premier jour d'abord nous protéger
protéger les plus vulnérables protéger
nos hôpitaux et nos soignants qui sont
sous forte pression alors même qu'il
faut soigner les autres maladies
protéger aussi notre économie et nos
emplois comme nous l'avons fait avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte ensuite nous
attacher sur la base des faits de la
science à prendre des mesures
proportionnées
c'est exactement ce que le premier
ministre et les ministres ont fait ces
derniers jours tout faire pour éviter de
prendre des restrictions qui pèsent sur
nos libertés et veiller à respecter tous
nos principes démocratiques
enfin nous appuyer sur la responsabilité
de chacun principalement se faisant
vacciner pour soi et pour les autres
être un citoyen libre et toujours être
un citoyen responsable pour soi et pour
autrui les devoirs valcke avant les
droits
un autre motif d'espoir et que malgré
les preuves sanitaire malgré la fatigue
la lassitude
notre pays continue à avancer nous
n'avons cessé d'oeuvrer pour attirer des
entreprises aidées investissement ouvrir
des usines créer des emplois jamais
depuis 15 ans le chômage n'avait été
aussi bas la réindustrialisation de
notre pays est bien une réalité
nous avons protéger les travailleurs et
des les plus modestes d'entre nous nous
avons investi pour défendre la dignité
de nos compatriotes en situation de
handicap pris des mesures et des
décisions claires pour mieux protéger
nos enfants accompagnez nos aînés nous
avons formé notre jeunesse en effet qui
aurait pensé que nous serions capables
en cinq ans de doubler le nombre de nos
apprentis près de 700000 apprentis ces
douze derniers mois que nous serions
inventer un programme un jeune une
solution qui a accompagné en un an et
demi plus de 3 millions de français vers
l'emploi ou la formation
là où nous aurions pu tout reporter nous
n'avons jamais renoncé à notre ambition
collective le travail avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le contrat
d'engagement jeunes qui sera mise en
oeuvre au début du mois de mars prochain
le pouvoir d'achat avec l'indemnité
inflation le chèque énergie
l'augmentation des salaires des
fonctionnaires les plus modestes
l'urgence écologique et climatique avec
le renouvellement de notre parc
automobile le développement des énergies
renouvelables rénovation thermique des
logements et au 1er janvier la fin des
emballages plastiques comme de nouvelles
mesures inédites pour le bien-être de
nos animaux notre agriculture avec
l'assurance récolte la retraite minimale
à 1000 euros
le déploiement de 2000 maisons de france
service le versement automatique des
pensions alimentaires qui bénéficiera
notamment aux mères seules la gratuité
de la contraception pour les femmes
jusqu'à 25 ans et la réforme de l'état
de notre haute fonction publique avec
entre autres la création de l'institut
national du service public rien que ces
dernières semaines et dans les prochains
mois des décisions dont on parlait
parfois depuis des décennies que je
viens à la cavalcade ici d'essayer de
rassembler ont été prises et seront
prises qui changeront la vie
la france malgré les épreuves et donc
plus forte aujourd'hui qu'il ya deux ans
tout cela c'est grâce à vous grâce à
nous tous grâce à notre esprit de
résistance notre solidarité notre
civisme notre engagement et notre esprit
d'entreprendre
alors au moment où je m'exprime devant
vous ce soir je veux vous dire que je
suis résolument optimiste pour l'année
qui vient optimiste pour notre nation
pas simplement pour 2022 mais pour les
années qui viennent car l'ambition et la
solidarité nous n'avons cessé de faire
preuve nous autorise tous les espoirs
2022 peut-être sera l'année de sortie de
l'épidémie je veux le croire avec vous
l'année où nous pouvons voir l'issue de
ce jour sans fin dans notre pays en
déployant ses campagnes de rappel ans
nous organisons comme il se doit pour
domestiquer le virus est écrasé sa
diffusion et au niveau mondial en
agissant pour vacciner l'humanité la
france dès avril 2020 a été à
l'initiative des dons de doses aux pays
les plus pauvres et nous serons au
rendez vous dans les prochains mois pour
amplifier l'effort et ainsi permettre
d'entrevoir la fin de ce virus sous sa
forme aiguë
2022 doit être l'année d'un tournant
européen
notre continent a été tant décrié ces
dernières années on l'a dit dit viser
incapable de projets collectifs en train
de sortir de l'histoire et alors même
que nous célébrons les 20 ans de la mise
en circulation de l'euro notre monnaie
commune qui nous aura donné une
stabilité monétaire une place
internationale inédite la crise a
démontré qu ni notre europe pouvait être
non seulement utile mais porteuse
d'espérance pour tous sans l'europe nous
n'aurions pas aujourd'hui de vaccins
disponibles en nombre y compris pour
organiser des campagnes de rappel sans
l'europe nous n'aurions pas pu bâtir
partout à travers notre continent des
plans de relance parmi les plus
ambitieux au monde et connaître les
résultats économiques croissance
création d'emplois que nous connaissons
alors à partir de minuit la france
prendra la présidence de l'union
européenne
et vous pouvez compter sur mon
engagement total pour faire de ce moment
qui ne survient qu'une fois tous les 13
ans
un temps de progrès pour vous un temps
de progrès pour la maîtrise de nos
frontières notre défense la transition
climatique
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la construction d'une alliance nouvelle
avec le continent africain le meilleur
encadrement des grandes plateformes de
l'internet et la culture en europe
oui les valeurs que porte notre union
européenne la démocratie l' équilibre
entre liberté solidarité une certaine
idée de l'homme sont j'en suis convaincu
celle qui permettront de relever nos
défis contemporains et notre europe est
bien le seul chemin par lequel la france
sera plus forte face au fracas du monde
et des grandes puissances
2022 sera pour la france une année
décisive une année d'action encore et
toujours fort de votre confiance
j'agirai jusqu'au dernier jour du mandat
pour lequel vous m'avez élu
bien sûr pour tenir le cap et prendre
toutes les décisions nécessaires face à
l'épidémie mais nous aurons aussi à
préparer l'avenir en déployant le plan
d'investissement france 2030 qui vise à
la fois à faire de nous une nation forte
sur les technologies du futur et à nous
rendre plus indépendant nous aurons à
investir plus fortement encore que nous
ne l'avons fait dans l'éducation la
recherche publique la santé la culture
et l'inclusion de tous les français
nous aurons à prendre de nouvelles
décisions pour lutter contre l'islamisme
radical renforcer l'ordre la sécurité et
la tranquillité de tous pour mieux vous
protéger nous aurons à prendre de
nouveaux choix industriels en
particulier en matière d'énergie inédits
afin de tenir nos engagements
climatiques
sera une année d'élection enfin nous
auront à élire au printemps prochain le
président de la république puis à
désigner nos représentants à l'assemblée
nationale
malgré la pandémie
ces scrutins essentiels devront se
dérouler dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et toutes les sensibilités
politiques du pays doivent oeuvrer j'y
veillerai tout ticulièrement
nous aurons donc cette année des choix
majeurs à faire pour notre nation ces
choix nous les ferons avec la conviction
que la france un chemin singulier unique
à poursuivre nous les ferons je le sais
en étant fidèle à l'esprit de résistance
l'esprit de tolérance et le choix de
notre avenir commun
qui nous ont toujours inspiré
pour ma part
quelle que soit ma place et les
circonstances
je continuerai à vous servir
et de la france notre patrie
nul ne saura déracinés mon coeur
mes chers compatriotes
j'ai travaillé et nous avons travaillé
sans relâche depuis bientôt cinq ans
afin que la france soit écoutée
respectée en europe et dans le concert
des nations elle l'est à faire
progresser notre pays dans l'unité aussi
chemin bien difficile car il est si aisé
d'opposer les générations les catégories
sociales les origines les territoires
mais chemin nécessaire
car lorsqu'il est rassemblé
rien ne peut résister au peuple français
en vous souhaitant ce soir une année
pleine de bonheur et d'accomplissement
personnel je forme donc pour nous tous
se veut
continuer à respecter nos différences
à avoir confiance en ce que nous sommes
a regardé avec courage audace et
lucidité
notre avenir pour agir
décidons pour nous même d'être tout à la
fois enracinés dans notre langue notre
culture notre laïcité
épris de liberté d'universel de
créativité
restons unis
bienveillant
solidaire
ce ton du côté de la vie
c'est là
ce que nous nous devons à nous mêmes
alors 2022 sera l'année de tous les
possibles
vive notre europe
vive la république
et vive la france
[Musique]
pour en parler pour parler de cette
allocution du président nous retrouvons
notre éditorialiste alexis poulain
bonsoir alexis et poulain merci d'être
avec nous alors vous venez d'écouter les
voeux du chef de l'état quelle est votre
analyse à chaud
à chaud j'ai vu déjà un spot de
publicité pour la vaccination quelles
que soient les vaccins et puis
l'ouverture de la présidence française
de l'union européenne qui va être prenez
le maquereau un moment important pour
préparer sa campagne donc vraiment un
satisfecit sur ce qu'il a fait france
2030 et c'est la façon dont elles il a
mis en scène son action et puis on a
appris ce soir que les devoirs et est
supérieur au droit est donc cette
vaccination même si elle n'est pas
obligatoire on sent bien que tout va
peser sur les non vaccinés c'est ce
message de ce soir et puis enfin un
lyrisme incroyable placer là où on ne
l'attendait pas notamment pour défendre
la fin des emballages plastiques on en a
vu toute une série de mesures emmanuel
macron était emporté 1 par la façon dont
il prépare son bilan parce qu'il y avait
un peu de bilan là dedans et effet au
final ces mots aussi qui m'ont marqué
quelle que soit ma place et les
circonstances je continuerai à vous
servir peut-être qu emmanuel macron est
en train de préparer sa défaite ou bien
sa non candidature parce qu'il se rend
compte que les choses sont en train
d'évoluer donc il ya beaucoup de choses
dans cette allocution qui n'était pas
extrêmement joyeuse disons le mais qui
étaient là pour poser une france unie
derrière un président de la
bienveillance justement alexis le
l'elysée promettait un discours
volontariste porteur d'espoir le
président at il été au rendez vous selon
vous
il est pété au rendez-vous de l'espoir
pas vraiment puisque tout le début était
sûr bien sûr les victimes du kovi kovi
delon ceux qui sont morts de ce virus
sur les difficultés bien sûr que nous
avons par rapport à ce virus et puis
l'espoir c'est simplement dans cette
action possible france 2030 les
nouvelles énergies enfin on très loin
finalement d'un espoir porté puisque nos
libertés vont encore être réduite
d'ailleurs il a commencé son allocution
pour dire que les semaines qui viennent
vont être très difficiles avec des
secteurs entiers qui vont à nouveau
devoir fermer ou avoir des activités
réduites donc espoir a minima on va dire
et pour beaucoup de français cette
allocution c'est la dernière des malades
macron donc l'espoir que il ne soit pas
candidat ou qu'ils aient une défaite en
2022 donc vraiment difficile pour lui de
porter un espoir parce qu'il va être à
jamais le président à la fois de la
violence lors des manifestations des
jeunes et puis celui de la crise du coc
vide crise du coc vite dans laquelle il
est empêtré depuis deux ans en
choisissant un mesures autoritaires en
choisissant aussi le fait de mettre la
pression sur les non vaccinés donc il
est loin de la bienveillance et de la
concorde ou de l'espoir qu'ils essayent
de mettre en scène par ces mots le
président a listé toute une série de
mesures économiques vous en parliez ou
dead l'accompagnement sur les apprentis
le chômage l'énergie l'augmentation
effectivement des salaires des
fonctionnaires le développement durable
est ce que vous êtes en phase avec ce
bilan positif
alors il ya des choses positives
notamment l'apprentissage évidemment
700000 apprenti il faut se réjouir ça
pourrait être beaucoup plus évidemment
et il ne parle pas du mal-être chez les
jeunes le nombre d'intentions de suicide
ou de suicides
le décrochage scolaire la difficulté
qu'ont les jeunes à vivre les que qu'on
a vu nombreuses devant les banques
alimentaires de ces jeunes qui
n'arrivent pas à vivre qui n'arrive pas
à voir l'espoir justement dans les
politiques des modèles macron donc il ya
beaucoup de non dits il ya beaucoup
d'angles morts dans cette façon de
présenter un bilan extrêmement positif
et tout est à minima les chiffres du
chômage encore une fois ils peuvent être
vues d'une façon ou d'une autre certains
chômeurs de catégorie a qui vont être en
formation mais qui ne vont pas forcément
trouver du travail la pression aussi
fait aujourd'hui on voit bien des
secteurs qui ont du mal à recruter et
ces secteurs là qui vont encore être
impactés par les mesures de coercition
de fermeture à cause de ce qu vide qui
n'en finit pas donc évidemment il ya des
bonnes choses à la marge mais
globalement ce qu'on voit c'est un
président qui a du mal à défendre un
bilan qui est quasiment inexistant
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il est allé
aussi vite qu'il parlait de cavalcade ça
permet de passer très vite sur des micro
réforme comme je le disais la fin des
emballages plastiques ok bon bah c'est
l'union européenne s'est pas forcément
emmanuel macron encore une fois mais là
où on l'attendait sur les réformes
structurelles réforme des retraites etc
c'est un échec à cause du coc but
dira-t-il mais même sur le fait de
donner un élan à ce pays à part faire
une dette abyssale une dette comme vide
abyssal que nous aurons du mal à
rembourser la politique des malades
macron aujourd'hui se résume à des
petites notes d'attention comme il vient
de le faire ce soir sur ce bilan
justement rien sur les mouvements
sociaux qui ont bousculé le quinquennat
rien sur le mouvement des gilet jaune
par exemple qu'en pensez vous c'est un
oubli volontaire
alors il faut dire que le mouvement des
gilet jaune même s'il perdure chaque
samedi date déjà davantage que de cette
année donc l'idée des malais macron
c'est de faire oublier année après année
ce qu'il s'est passé donc il n'y fait
pas référence évidemment mais il
pourrait parler de ce qui se passe
actuellement en guadeloupe dans des
territoires d'outre-mer avec
l'arrestation d'un leader syndical avec
une mobilisation importante dans ces
territoires contre le pass vaccinale
avec aussi le fait que évidemment les
mouvements sociaux continuent les
soignants sont toujours en colère les
urgentistes n'ont jamais été entendus
aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui sont encore
en première ligne avec très peu de
moyens si ce n'est le vaccin pour éviter
potentiellement des formes graves mais
c'est bien peu par rapport au lit qui
ont continué de fermer par rapport aux
moyens de l'hôpital public qui ont
continué d'être limité à la marge pour
faire un hôpital de flux donc on voit
bien que là encore une fois c'est ce
principe de l'allocution des angles
morts se présenter sous son meilleur
jour et il ne va pas faire autre chose
on le comprend mais la réalité c'est
qu'il veut occulter ce pays qui bout qui
gronde la pétition plus d'un million de
signatures contre le pass vaccinale et
bien il le disait lors du grand débat
vous parliez des gilet jaune à l'issue
des gilet jaune il a monopolisé la
parole et à l'issue de la conférence de
presse qu'il a donnée il a dit que avec
une pétition à un million de signatures
il était possible de déclencher pourquoi
pas il faudrait changer la loi à
référendum d'initiative parlementaire
pour évidemment faire un référendum
national est bien là on a une pétition
qui a plus d'un million de signatures
c'est exceptionnel entre le pass
sanitaires at il mentionné cette
pétition non at il parlé du passé ni
terre non plus il a fait beaucoup de
circonvolutions autour de cette mesure
liberticide sans jamais en parler c'est
des non dits qui disent tout en réalité
emmanuel macron avance caché il a un
masque et il est là pour nous masquer
pour nous priver de liberté et derrière
ils parlent de bienveillance il parle
d'unité et il parle d'espoir il est tout
d'un verre sans réalité selon un sondage
aux hawks a réalisé par internet les 21
et 22 décembre dernier seuls 17% des
français pensent que l'année 2022 sera
meilleur que 2021 et surtout ils passent
au premier rang de leurs préoccupations
la santé le pouvoir d'achat est ce que
vous pensez qu emmanuel macron était en
phase avec ses préoccupations alors il a
parlé évidemment de prix mais il a parlé
de robes et les réalisations des
salaires des fonctionnaires les plus
pauvres les moins dotées il a parlé de
primes énergie et cetera sur le pouvoir
d'achat le problème il est lé d'abord
les salaires mais emmanuel macron ne n'y
peut pas grand chose en réalité c'est
les entreprises c'est le marché c'est
les syndicats qui vont pouvoir négocier
en force en disant nous pouvons
maintenant demandé à être payé davantage
le problème c'est l'inflation et si les
salaires augmentent du côté de la banque
centrale européenne comme du côté du
patronat on sait très bien que
l'inflation sera incontrôlable elle est
déjà difficilement contrôlable donc il a
très peu de pouvoir sur le pouvoir
d'achat en réalité à part faire quelques
chèques ou bien augmenter massivement
les fonctionnaires mais s'il le fait il
sait très bien qu'il ira à l'encontre
des politiques européennes qui lui
demande de faire attention à
l'endettement même si l'endettement est
devenu fou ces dernières années à cause
du coc vide donc évidemment que ce qu'il
propose est a minima de l'ordre de la
prime de l'ordre de l'anecdotique comme
lors de la crise des gilet jaune où il
avait demandé aux entreprises de faire
un effort de donner une prime pour
éviter que ce pays ne fasse une
révolution parce qu'il pendante est
quasiment au board de ce gouffre là et
là on a à la fois les mêmes problèmes
que lord et gilet jaune le pouvoir
d'achat la fin de mois difficiles un
avenir compliqué pour les enfants avec
en plus des problématiques sanitaires
qui ont amené une gestion autoritaire
avec la réduction des libertés
je vois pas comment on peut penser que
le pays va mieux en 2021 qu'en 2018 et
comment il pourra aller mieux en 2022
avec un gouvernement qui s'entête dans
des mesures inacceptables comme celle du
pass sanitaires ou bien toujours de
montrer la politique du bouc émissaire
de montrer du doigt les non vaccinés qui
serait responsable de tout or on le sait
maintenant au micron par exemple en
allemagne l'institut coop qui est une
des autorités de santé de allemande a
bien montré que les vaccinés était
vecteur de l'épidémie de mikron sans
faire de cas graves et heureusement mais
voilà la réalité c'est que on ne peut
pas parler d'épidémie de non vaccinés
c'est un non-sens sanitaire ce que fait
pourtant emmanuel macron en choisissant
volontairement et de manière extrêmement
cynique une politique du bouc-émissaire
indigne de notre république la france
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne pour six mois à partir de
demain emmanuel macron a dit qu'il
ferait de ce temps un temps de progrès
que cela passait par la maîtrise de nos
frontières de la défense du climat de
l'égalité hommes-femmes que ça passera
également par la culture est
effectivement la démocratie il a dit que
c'était le seul chemin pour être plus
fort est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
le chef de l'état
alors c'est assez étonnant parce que
quand il parle d'europe il parle
évidemment de mesures incapable de
défendre les frontières de la défense de
lutter contre les gars femme de
coopération avec les pays frères
africains il parle en réalité de
souveraineté or l'union européenne telle
qu'elle est faite aujourd'hui est une
armée mexicaine où c'est très difficile
d'avoir des prises de décisions qui vont
aller à tous les états puisque que ce
soit les allemands les français les
italiens les espagnols ou les pays bas
nous avons des intérêts divergents
notamment en afrique où notamment dans
des pays
limitrophes où nous ne sommes pas tous
des pays frontières donc il est là dans
une vision romantique fantasmes et de
l'union européenne qui arriverait à un
fédéralisme ou tous les états pourraient
avoir enfin une gestion
unique centralisé à bruxelles celle de
la commission bien sûr celle du conseil
aussi
d'européens mais on en est très très
loin aujourd'hui on a une division on le
voit avec la pologne on le voit avec la
hongrie on le voit avec les pays qui
sont les pays frontières on le voit
aussi avec l'achat ou la vente d'armes
des pays européens ne choisissent pas
des armes françaises ou allemandes ou
italiennes et préfèrent acheter
américain par exemple on le voit aussi
avec l'otan qui s'immisce dans les
politiques européennes en réalité cette
présidence de l'union européenne ne
servira qu'à une chose pause et emmanuel
macron en défenseur bien sûr du progrès
européens vers toujours plus
d'intégration fédéraliste et puis faire
croire à une souveraineté européenne
pensant que la france n'est pas soluble
dans quelque chose qui ne lui servira à
rien si ce n'est à éponger une dette
qu'elle ne pourra pas rembourser seule
l'énergie aussi aujourd'hui l'union
européenne telle qu'elle est faite n'a
pas permis de faire émerger un champion
européen de l'énergie pourquoi parce que
c'est la concurrence qui prime parce que
c'est la compétition entre chaque état
européen qui fait la loi plutôt que la
coopération donc il faudrait revoir tout
de a à z tous les traités
fondamentalement or émail macron n'est
pas là pour faire une révolution même
s'il avait écrit un livre qui avaient ce
titre c'est tout l'inversé il est là
pour assurer que le monde d'hier perdure
dans ce monde à eau qui a du mal à voir
le jour finalement pour arriver à
redonner le pouvoir au peuple simplement
parce que c'est la promesse finalement
de la république le pouvoir du peuple
par le peuple pour le peuple on en est
très loin on voit bien que derrière
cette allocution est bien il y a cette
idée de une europe qui protège une
europe sociale toujours
mentionné jamais incarné c'est encore
une fois une belle poésie carey cité
mail macron sur l'union européenne merci
pour votre analyse alexis
est bon réveillon à vous
ici merci merci alexis et on se retrouve
d'ici une trentaine de minutes pour une
nouvelle page d'actualité
[Musique]
le doute plane encore sur la tenue de la
can 2022 au cameroun la caf réfléchirai
à annuler la compétition quelles sont
vos informations c'est clairement une
fake news aujourd'hui à l'afrique cette
campagne d appliquer jupe comme un
sabotage pour cette can à 2022 les yeux
sont rivés sur le fameux stade de limbé
confronté à des retards de travaux et un
scandale financier présumé avec le
nouveau père à la fécafoot nous savons
que les choses vont se passer pour les
six points c'est pas tous les pays
africains qui selon de désormais capable
d'organiser une canne à vingt quatre
équipes ne peut pas priver les africains
d'europe compétition phare la cale iii
souverain brawn et débute le 9 janvier
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur les db c'est une réalité hopitalisés
il était nulle part est ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sens du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec un invité
qui va sans doute vous surprendre didier
barbelivien bonjourbonjour auteur
compositeur interprète
vous êtes connu mais vos chansons le
sont peut-être encore beaucoup plus que
vous j'espère qu'on qu'on connaît plus
méchants sont deux points de chansons